Musique mélancolique
...
-C'est l'histoire d'un tabou.
Celui de femmes violées par ceux
en qui elles avaient confiance
et qui devaient les soigner :
leurs médecins.
...
C'est l'histoire d'un scandale,
celui des violeurs
en blouse blanche,
dont les agressions
sont si souvent couvertes
par l'ordre des médecins.
...
Jackie dit
avoir été violée
par son psychiatre
lors de plusieurs consultations.
-La première fois,
j'allais partir
et puis il me prend...
Il me prend et me dit :
"Vous sentez
que je vous désire, Jackie ?
"Je suis en train de bander."
Il me prend la main,
puis il me la met sur son sexe.
Il me dit : "Vous sentez ?
J'ai du désir pour vous."
Là, on a eu
une relation... Enfin, non.
Un passage à l'acte.
Debout, contre le radiateur...
Et la porte du cabinet,
en fait.
Musique glaçante
-Nous sommes en octobre 2022.
Cela fait plus de 10 ans
que nous filmons Jackie,
année après année.
Ambiance bucolique
...
La première fois
que nous la rencontrons,
cette ancienne fonctionnaire
habite en Corse,
sur les hauteurs d'Ajaccio.
Elle tousse.
Elle a porté plainte
contre son psychiatre.
C'est le début
d'un long combat judiciaire
que nous allons filmer
pas à pas.
Un parcours qui commence
par une déception.
Le portable sonne.
-Allô ?
Oui.
-Elle vient d'apprendre
que le juge a conclu
à un non-lieu,
mais qu'il reconnaît
quand même l'existence
des actes sexuels.
*-Donc voilà,
ça existe, cette possibilité.
-Attendez...
C'est quand même phénoménal.
"Il est considéré
que Jean-Philippe Sicard
"a eu des rapports sexuels,
fellation et pénétration vaginale,
"avec Jackie de Mari."
Ils reconnaissent quand même,
dans le papier,
qu'il y a eu fellation
et pénétration dans son cabinet.
*-Oui.
-C'est grave.
-Dans ce courrier,
le juge considère
que les deux adultes
sont consentants.
Il ne prend pas en compte
la relation d'autorité
entre un médecin
et sa patiente.
-Quand on va voir
un psychiatre,
on se met à nu.
On raconte sa vie.
Il sait beaucoup de choses
sur vous.
Il connaît vos failles...
Votre fragilité...
Il a joué dessus.
-Le psychiatre aurait profité
des vulnérabilités
de sa patiente
pour sortir progressivement
de son rôle de soignant.
-Crescendo,
en disant qu'il serait
toujours là pour moi,
que j'étais séduisante,
que je le troublais,
que j'étais une jolie femme,
que j'étais intelligente,
pas comme ses autres patientes
qui étaient hystériques,
il a commencé
à me caresser les cheveux,
à me faire des massages,
à m'embrasser.
Jusqu'au jour où il y a eu
des passages à l'acte.
-Jackie a consulté
ce psychiatre
parce qu'elle est tombée
en dépression,
suite à des agressions sexuelles
subies depuis son enfance.
-C'est quelqu'un
qui a déjà subi,
qu'on va pouvoir contraindre
assez facilement
et à qui
on va pouvoir faire penser
que ce n'est pas vraiment un viol,
qu'elle veut ça.
C'est une stratégie
d'agresseur de base :
choisir des victimes.
Là, le choix de la victime
est fait
sur une certaine fragilité.
C'est ensuite
inverser la culpabilité,
laisser penser qu'en fait,
elle le veut bien.
La confusion est telle
chez des gens fragiles
que ça risque de pouvoir durer
assez longtemps.
-Elle a beaucoup hésité
avant de porter plainte.
-A un moment donné,
j'ai pensé que pour sauver ma vie,
il n'y avait que la plainte.
Sinon, je pense que je serais
encore dans son cabinet.
Ou peut-être
que je me serais suicidée.
Ca l'aurait bien arrangé.
Je me serais bien tue.
Elle respire fort.
-Jackie ne s'est pas tue.
Elle a brisé l'omerta,
osé dénoncer un notable,
et ses proches
lui ont tourné le dos.
9 autres patientes,
victimes du même docteur,
interrogées
par le juge d'instruction,
n'auraient pas eu le courage
de porter plainte.
-Il y a encore des citrons.
-Pour ne plus jamais croiser
son agresseur,
elle s'apprête
à quitter la Corse.
-Ici, c'est tellement petit que...
Tout le monde se frôle
et se connaît.
Sur Paris, je serai mieux.
On revient toujours à dire :
"J'ai été violée.
Je subis la double peine."
Moi, je pars,
et lui, il reste.
Ce qui va me manquer le plus,
c'est les odeurs,
la mer et les montagnes.
Elle retient ses larmes.
Musique mélancolique
...
-Les violences sexuelles
font dérailler la vie des victimes.
Trois mois
après avoir quitté son île,
Jackie vit dans la précarité,
sans travail, sans ressources.
Elle est sans domicile fixe.
...
-Je vis d'abord chez une copine,
à Montreuil,
qui m'a gardée
pendant un an et demi.
Après...
Je vis à droite et à gauche.
Ca veut dire que je n'ai pas
de logement fixe.
Tous les deux ou trois jours,
je suis obligée
de changer de logement.
...
J'ai été hébergée
à Gif-sur-Yvette,
à Evry, à Ivry,
dans le 15e, dans le 14e,
dans le 78, dans le 77...
Dans le 91...
Dans le 94...
Et dans des hôtels parisiens.
Je voudrais un petit pain au raisin,
un pain comme ça.
...
Sirènes de police
-Ce qui l'aide à tenir,
c'est qu'elle a décidé
de faire appel du non-lieu prononcé
par le juge.
...
-Le juge sait
qu'il y a d'autres victimes,
signalées à la police,
mais ce n'est pas à lui
de chercher la vérité à tout prix
hors de son champ de saisine.
Comment un juge d'instruction...
Qu'il aille à charge ou à décharge,
je peux comprendre,
mais il sait,
dans son intime conviction,
qu'il y a d'autres victimes.
Comment peut-il prononcer
un non-lieu
et laisser continuer cet homme ?
Pour moi, en tant que victime,
je suis choquée.
Musique énigmatique
...
-Dans ce temps suspendu,
avant la prochaine audience,
isolée,
c'est sur Internet
qu'elle trouve du réconfort.
-Facebook, c'est mon lien,
c'est un réseau social
où il y a beaucoup de victimes
qui ont vécu la même chose.
On se soutient mutuellement.
En fait, j'écris sur Facebook :
"Je vais pas bien",
"Je me sens mal",
"Je vais pas y arriver",
"J'arriverai jamais
à la fin de la procédure"...
"Aidez-moi"
ou "J'ai peur. Aidez-moi.
"Je suis comme une petite fille
perdue. Aidez-moi.
"Je me sens seule."
Et là, mes copines
de Facebook, virtuelles,
me répondent et m'encouragent,
ou passent un coup de fil.
Elles me disent : "Tu vas y arriver.
On est là. On va t'aider.
"Tu es une guerrière.
Tu es la plus forte.
"Tu vas y arriver."
Et ça, ça m'encourage
et je vais mieux.
Musique apaisante
...
Musique énigmatique
-Des victimes de médecin,
nous en avons rencontré plusieurs,
à une époque où la parole des femmes
était peu entendue.
Certaines ont choisi l'écriture
comme exutoire.
Anne était mineure
au moment des faits.
...
-Je suis cette petite fille
assise sur les genoux de cet adulte
si grand et fort,
ce monsieur très costaud
et bardé de diplômes,
comme un général le serait
de décorations,
et j'ignore ce qui va maintenant
se passer.
J'ai peur.
Je suis un petit objet sans force
à la merci de ses grands bras.
Le monsieur m'embrasse
sur les lèvres.
Il me traite comme une femme adulte
que je ne suis pas.
...
-L'homme dont elle parle
est le docteur Jean-Paul Guittet,
psychiatre au Mans.
Accusé d'agressions sexuelles
par plusieurs patientes,
il a été sanctionné
en fin de carrière.
Des cloches retentissent.
...
-Ce psychiatre
devait aider Anne
a surmonté sa dépression
après le suicide de son grand frère.
-Je le voyais
depuis que j'avais
14 ans et demi.
Il m'avait dit
que si j'étais, un jour,
vraiment en difficulté,
je pouvais passer le voir
à l'improviste.
Donc, j'ai beaucoup hésité,
mais comme il m'avait invité
à venir le voir
si ça allait vraiment pas,
ce jour-là,
j'étais particulièrement fragilisée,
donc je me suis rendue chez lui.
Et donc, en fait...
Là, il me voit.
Il me fait signe d'entrer
avant de prendre quelqu'un d'autre,
car il voit que je suis
dans sa salle d'attente.
En fait, je fonds en larmes.
Je fonds en larmes, et là...
En fait,
il me prend par les mains,
il m'attire à lui comme ça.
Il m'embrasse sur la bouche
et il me dit un truc du style :
"Je sais qu'il y a des liens
qui peuvent se créer,
"mais je veux pas du tout
te faire mal."
C'est à peu près...
Peut-être que...
Il y a quelques mots
que je fais varier,
mais c'est à peu près le sens exact,
la phrase exacte.
Puis, petit à petit, aussi,
il passe sous mes vêtements,
il met ses mains sur ma poitrine...
Il joue toujours sur des registres
un peu parallèles et différents,
en parlant de tendresse,
en parlant d'amitié,
et puis, en mêlant avec des choses
plus sexualisées, en fait.
Ca crée une confusion en moi,
parce qu'en plus, je suis jeune,
je suis ado,
j'ai jamais eu de petit ami...
Elle respire fort.
Voilà, c'était là.
C'était là.
Son credo,
c'était de me dire
qu'il voulait être le premier
à me faire l'amour,
parce que ce serait avec quelqu'un
qui m'aimait.
C'était ça, sa came.
C'était prétendument un service
qu'il me rendait, en fait.
Musique douce à la guitare
...
Comment on peut faire confiance
à quelqu'un après ça ?
Comment on peut
vraiment faire confiance ?
En fait, je me dis
que si ça avait été
un étranger dans la rue,
j'aurais eu peur, mais on sait
qu'on peut en avoir peur.
Le type que l'on connaît
depuis longtemps...
Ca faisait 2 ans
que je le connaissais.
J'avais déposé les armes,
donné ma confiance,
et c'est là qu'il agit.
Après, on se dit
que c'est difficile
de faire confiance dans l'existence,
même à un compagnon
ou dans des relations.
On a toujours peur
de le payer très cher,
en fait.
*-Négation des violences !
Brisons le silence !
Exclamations des manifestants
-Jackie, la Corse,
est à Paris depuis 6 mois.
Elle attend toujours
que la justice
se prononce en appel
sur sa plainte
contre son psychiatre.
-Elles y sont pas, hein ?
Propos au mégaphone indistincts
-Face au silence imposé
par l'attente de son jugement,
elle se rapproche
des milieux féministes
pour faire entendre sa voix.
-Aline et Delphine.
-Ca va ?
-La victime est devenue militante.
-J'ai eu du mal à arriver.
Je me suis gouré de métro.
Bonjour !
Il y a le journaliste,
derrière, pour filmer.
-Comment tu vas bien ?
-Il y a Xavier. Il peut filmer ?
-Oui.
-Oui ?
-Bonjour.
-L'affaire Dominique Strauss-Kahn,
qui a éclaté
quelques mois auparavant,
a galvanisé
les collectifs féministes.
Le viol est devenu
une affaire politique.
-DSK, c'est un homme politique
d'importance
qui risque d'être
président de la République
qui tombe, qui est incarcéré,
parce qu'il est pris la main
dans le sac, pour dire ça joliment.
C'était : 1, c'est possible
de faire tomber quelqu'un qui viole,
pas chez nous,
mais il est quand même tombé,
2 : c'est possible
qu'un homme politique
de haut niveau soit un violeur
et soit condamné,
ou en tout cas,
sérieusement empêché
de continuer une carrière comme ça.
C'est ce moment clé
qui a commencé, à mon avis,
a retourné l'opinion publique.
-NON !
-Si l'opinion publique
commence à entendre les victimes,
la justice condamne
toujours aussi peu
les agresseurs sexuels.
-Oui, c'est ça.
-LE CORPS DES FEMMES
N'EST PAS UNE MARCHANDISE.
Musique calme
...
-En 2013,
Jackie retourne en Corse
pour la première fois.
...
Elle est convoquée
à la Cour d'appel de Bastia.
...
C'est sa dernière chance
de faire condamner son psychiatre.
...
Ca commence.
-Cette fois encore, Jackie
ne réussit pas à se faire entendre.
Les juges considèrent
que l'emprise psychologique
du médecin
sur sa patiente
n'est pas caractérisée.
-Ils connaissent peu le dossier
des violences commises
par les médecins
et de l'autorité que peut avoir
un médecin sur sa patiente,
cette facilité d'entrer
dans le corps de l'autre
et dans son intimité, en fait.
C'est facile pour un médecin.
S'il dit à une patiente
de se déshabiller,
elle se déshabille.
Musique pesante
...
-L'affaire se termine
par un non-lieu.
Comme dans 99 % des cas
en France,
l'agresseur présumé ne sera pas
condamné par la justice pénale.
...
Musique intrigante
Jackie a décidé
de ne pas en rester là,
et de faire appel
à l'Ordre des médecins,
...
un ordre professionnel chargé,
entre autres,
de juger les contentieux
entre médecins et patients.
...
Mais que pèse
la parole d'une patiente
face à un médecin
jugé par ses confrères ?
-Quand il y a
des violences sexuelles
et qu'une plaignante arrive
jusqu'au conseil de l'Ordre,
la plupart du temps,
il ne se passe rien.
Objectivement,
ils ont une position
de complices des agresseurs sexuels.
Je peux pas le dire autrement.
-J'ai le cahier.
Y a déjà des trucs écrits.
-Quelques mois plus tard,
Jackie s'apprête à passer
devant cette justice.
-Le docteur "S", c'est ça ?
-Elle est avec un ami
qui découvre l'affaire.
A quelques jours de l'audience,
elle est inquiète.
-Tu crois que devant
le conseil de l'Ordre,
moi qui n'ai plus confiance
en les médecins,
je vais arriver
tranquille, pimpante ?
-J'ai pas dit ça.
-Il va y en avoir 12, devant moi.
Tu crois que ça me fait plaisir ?
J'ai peur des médecins,
je ne me fais même plus soigner.
-Il est psychiatre,
il sait que c'est une connerie.
-Oui.
-Il devrait dire : "J'ai fait
une connerie avec ma patiente.
"On rectifie,
on arrête la thérapie,
"mais on ne reste pas comme ça."
-Eh non.
-C'est un élément important.
-Bah écris-le.
Aux Etats-Unis, au Canada,
tout thérapeute n'a pas le droit
d'avoir de relation amoureuse
ou sexuelle avec sa patiente,
même deux ans
après la thérapie,
parce qu'il peut avoir
une relation d'emprise.
-C'est des choses qui peuvent
être amenées pour dire qu'il y a
des réflexions,
que c'est pas normal.
-Le conseil de l'Ordre,
même si ce ne sont
pas des juges,
c'est une manière
d'être reconnue aussi,
d'une autre manière.
Je suis reconnue
quand même comme ayant été...
abusée par un médecin.
Musique pesante
...
-C'est à Marseille,
au conseil régional
de l'Ordre des médecins,
que Jackie sera entendue.
...
Elle est accompagnée
de son avocate
et d'une psychologue
militante féministe.
...
Pour la première fois
depuis trois ans,
Jackie sera confrontée
à son agresseur.
La Chambre disciplinaire est
composée de plusieurs médecins
et présidée par un magistrat.
-Quand on rentre,
y a une espèce d'estrade.
Il y a 12 hommes qui siègent,
habillés en noir et rouge.
Oui, c'est assez impressionnant,
quoi.
C'est solennel,
et puis il y a des tables :
il y a Sicard sur le côté gauche,
avec son avocat,
moi sur le côté droit,
avec mon avocate.
Quand j'ai croisé son regard,
je n'avais plus peur de lui.
C'est important.
Je n'avais plus peur de lui.
Lui, il vous regardait pas.
Musique émouvante
...
-Le psychiatre risque
un simple avertissement,
un blâme,
ou une radiation temporaire.
...
La décision est rendue
deux mois plus tard.
-"Le fait pour un médecin
d'entretenir
"avec un de ses patients
une relation intime
"constitue une faute
susceptible d'être sanctionnée
"par les instances disciplinaires
de la profession.
"Il est interdit au Dr Sicard
"d'exercer la médecine
pendant une année.
"La sanction visée ci-dessus
"prendra effet
le 1er juillet 2014 à 00h00
"pour s'achever
le 30 juin 2015 à 24h00."
C'était une victoire, pour moi.
-Un an de radiation.
*Tonalités
Pour prendre la mesure
de la sanction...
-Allo ?
-...Jackie appelle
le conseil de l'Ordre de Marseille.
-Oui ?
-Non.
-Je me sens reconnue comme victime,
et en plus, la lettre de motivation
est bien écrite :
l'ascendant du médecin,
la dépendance qu'on a
par rapport à son médecin...
-La sanction aurait pu
être plus lourde.
*-Voilà, après...
-Quand j'ai été porter plainte
à la police,
ils ont été à son cabinet,
ils ont fait une perquisition,
ils ont interrogé sur 3 ans
toute sa patientèle.
Ils ont retrouvé 9 victimes
qui n'ont pas voulu porter plainte
parce qu'elles avaient peur.
-Oui, c'est important.
Au revoir. Bonne journée.
*-Au revoir.
-Hop !
Les 5 ans, là.
-A Jackie.
-On a gagné ! On a gagné !
-Elle ignore que le Dr Sicard
va faire appel,
ce qui lui permettra
de continuer à exercer.
Musique pesante
C'est un procès inédit
qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui
devant la Cour d'assises de Paris.
Dans le box :
le Dr André Hazout,
gynécologue réputé,
reconnu pour ses travaux
sur la fécondation in vitro.
Il va pourtant devoir répondre
à six de ses anciennes patientes,
qui l'accusent
d'agressions sexuelles et de viols.
...
A mi-chemin
entre l'affaire DSK
et le mouvement MeToo,
pour la première fois,
un médecin accusé de viol
fait la une de la presse nationale.
Ce procès va révéler l'inaction
du conseil de l'Ordre.
A l'origine de l'affaire,
le couple Cécile
et Richard Poitevin.
Ils ont consulté le Dr Hazout
dans l'espoir d'avoir un enfant.
Les faits se sont produits
quand Cécile
était seule en consultation.
Elle en parle
immédiatement à son mari.
-Je l'ai évidemment crue,
parce que ça,
je pense que c'est la différence
avec certains conjoints ou maris
qui ont fait que certaines femmes
ne leur en ont pas parlé,
parce qu'elles avaient peur
de leur réaction,
ou d'une réaction,
au contraire, de jalousie.
Moi, je l'ai crue tout de suite,
je l'ai soutenue et voilà,
on est partis...
On est partis en guerre,
quelque part, tous les deux.
-Ca fait 9 ans que ça dure.
9 ans de notre vie, quand même.
-Pour éviter un non-lieu,
Richard et Cécile
ont d'abord dû trouver par eux-mêmes
d'autres victimes.
-Telle qu'avait été réalisée
cette agression,
je me doutais qu'il y avait
certainement d'autres cas.
Donc j'en ai...
J'ai laissé des...
Disons que j'ai tendu des perches
sur Internet à l'aide d'un pseudo
sur Doct... sur deux sites :
Doctissimo et Auféminin.com,
de manière à savoir si des femmes
avaient pu être agressée
par ce même médecin.
-C'est comme ça
qu'on a récupéré des témoignages.
-On les a récupérés
assez facilement.
-Le couple a retrouvé
une quarantaine
de victimes présumées,
témoignant d'agressions
commises pendant plusieurs
dizaines d'années par le Dr Hazout.
-Le fait qu'un violeur...
n'ait qu'une pulsion
et ne commette qu'un viol,
c'est dans les rêves
des personnes.
En vrai, un violeur,
c'est un violeur.
Il pense en violeur.
Du coup, évidemment,
il y a plein de victimes.
Maintenant qu'on a réfléchi
autour de ça,
à la permanence téléphonique,
depuis plusieurs années,
on demande aux personnes :
"Vous savez s'il a violé
d'autres personnes ?"
Plus de 50 % des victimes savent
qu'il a violé d'autres personnes,
qui connaissent...
En vrai, je ne pense pas
qu'il y ait un seul violeur
qui ne viole qu'une fois.
-Les faisceaux concordant,
donc des témoignages identiques
pour des faits identiques
par des personnes
qui ne se connaissent pas,
clairement,
pour nous en tous cas,
ça a été ce qui a fait
qu'aujourd'hui,
il est renvoyé
devant les assises. Voilà.
-Pour Jackie, dont le médecin
n'a pas été condamné au pénal,
le procès du Dr Hazout
est un procès par procuration.
-En fait, quand j'ai rencontré
d'autres victimes de médecins,
j'ai trouvé une solidarité,
je leur ai apporté mon soutien,
parce qu'on a
des histoires différentes,
mais c'est à peu près
les mêmes histoires.
Il y a une solidarité.
On a été victimes de violences
commises par un médecin.
-Face à Dr Hazout,
six victimes reconnues,
et 30 autres femmes
venues témoigner
pour des faits prescrits,
comme Marie.
-Il dit :
"J'ai toujours été sincère."
-Ah bon ?
-La sincérité,
c'est pas des excuses.
-Il s'est pas excusé ?
-Bah non.
-Il s'est excusé auprès
de sa femme.
-Ouais. Sa femme, ses collègues...
mais pas aux filles
qui étaient là, quoi.
-Et comment tu te sens ?
-Je suis tendue.
Je suis tendue, tendue.
Moi, j'ai arrêté de vivre,
j'avais 25 ans.
J'en ai 52, bientôt.
J'ai arrêté.
C'est tout une partie de ma vie.
Il me reste quoi, moi,
maintenant ?
Je n'ai pas d'enfants.
Il m'a cassée.
Qu'est-ce qu'il me reste ?
Il me reste rien.
J'ai plus rien.
J'ai la rage, je suis...
J'ai une page à tourner
et je vais pas y arriver comme ça.
Je pensais que
ce serait un exutoire,
et que ce serait
la seule manière de me sortir de ça,
et je m'en sortirai pas.
Je m'en sortirai pas,
c'est une blessure ouverte.
J'attends beaucoup
de cet après-midi.
Mais je...
Je sais que ce sera pas fini.
-L'avocat général a requis
12 ans d'incarcération.
Après des semaines de procès,
le médecin violeur est condamné
à 8 ans de prison.
-Mettez-vous sur les marches.
Restez au milieu. Voilà. C'est bon.
Il vient d'être condamné
à 8 ans de prison.
Qu'avez-vous ressenti ?
-La paix. Enfin, la paix.
Depuis 85...
Voilà... Je...
J'ai besoin de rentrer chez moi.
-Vous avez le sentiment
que votre parole a été entendue ?
Que le viol ait été reconnu,
c'est l'impression pour vous d'avoir
été entendue par les jurés ?
-Ah oui. Oui. Tout à fait.
Ce qui est merveilleux,
sans doute, aujourd'hui,
c'est d'avoir été entendue.
Tous...
Tous ces discours ignominieux
qui ont été tenus.
-Je peux pas. Vraiment, je peux pas.
Merci. Merci à vous.
-Une justice bien tardive.
Le conseil de l'Ordre avait reçu
des plaintes depuis les années 90.
Et n'avait pas réagi.
-Cette affaire a été
un désastre
ordinal.
Le conseil de l'Ordre
doit donc réfléchir
sur les règles,
qui consistent avant tout,
à protéger les patientes,
lorsqu'elles viennent
faire des dénonciations.
Je rappelle qu'il a fallu 25 ans
pour qu'enfin, effectivement,
le conseil de l'Ordre prenne
les dispositions nécessaires.
-Ce procès, il a montré
que oui, des médecins
pouvaient être violeurs
et pouvaient être condamnés.
Ca, pour nous, c'était important.
Ca a pas suffi pour que le conseil
de l'Ordre continue à défendre
les femmes victimes
mais ça a été un premier pas.
Musique douce
...
-Un an a passé.
-C'est la porte rouge.
-De nouveau,
Jackie va devoir affronter
son ancien psychiatre
qui a fait appel de sa condamnation
à un an de radiation.
-Nous y sommes.
-Salut, ça va ?
-Tu vas bien ?
-Oui.
-Elle est entourée de membres
du Collectif féministe
contre le viol.
Debout, à quelques mètres d'elle,
le médecin,
qu'elle accuse de viol.
-Il est là. En face.
Je tremble.
Vas-y, fais le paravent.
-Venez par ici.
-Ca me stresse.
Je suis stressée.
C'est inadmissible,
de la part du conseil national
de l'Ordre des médecins
d'accueillir les victimes
de violences sexuelles
de la part d'un médecin,
dans une petite salle d'accueil,
face à son agresseur.
C'était d'une violence inouïe.
-Au moment de l'audience,
le docteur exerce toujours
car l'appel est suspensif.
Devant ses confrères,
le psychiatre nie le viol.
Puisque les actes sexuels
ont été reconnus par la justice,
il accuse son ancienne
patiente d'érotomanie.
-Inverser la culpabilité,
c'est la stratégie
des agresseurs sexuels.
Tous les agresseurs sexuels,
le médecin y compris.
Ce qu'il veut que tu crois,
quand t'es victime,
c'est que tu l'as cherché,
qu'il a bien été gentil.
Quand on analyse ce qui s'est passé,
c'est exactement le contraire.
Elles ont été piégées et n'ont pas
vu quand ça se passait mais...
C'est une vraie stratégie,
une toile d'araignée à laquelle
elles peuvent
difficilement résister.
-Face à la chambre disciplinaire,
la défense du docteur Sicard
a fonctionné.
La chambre réduit de moitié
sa condamnation.
-J'ai beaucoup pleuré. Enormément.
J'ai pas eu l'impression
qu'ils m'aient écoutée, en fait.
C'était...
Je... Je...
"Je protège mon confrère."
-Le psychiatre est puni
de 6 mois de radiation
à effet immédiat.
-Rares sont celles
qui parviennent
à se faire entendre
par la justice ordinale.
15 ans après avoir
fréquenté le cabinet
du docteur Guittet au Mans,
devenu journaliste,
Anne a signalé au conseil de l'Ordre
les agressions sexuelles
qu'elle dit avoir subies
étant mineure.
Elle est la 3e patiente
à mettre en cause ce psychiatre,
mais c'est elle qu'on accuse
de s'être jetée dans ses bras.
Sa plainte est rejetée
par les médecins.
-Ce sont des hommes assez âgés,
et donc, effectivement,
je pense que c'est une certaine
culture qui s'exprime.
C'est comme ça que je comprends
la décision prise contre moi
d'aller affirmer
contre toute évidence
que c'était moi qui avait
pris l'initiative de...
De ce qui s'est passé avec
ce professionnel de santé.
Sans souci aucun
pour les conséquences,
pour moi,
d'une telle affirmation.
C'est gravissime. On a déjà beaucoup
de culpabilité, beaucoup de honte,
et ces gens-là viennent
donner un bâton à l'agresseur
pour vous taper sur la figure.
C'est vraiment...
C'est effroyable, en fait...
C'est désespérant.
J'ai été désespérée.
Je me suis dit : "Je vis dans
un monde qui n'a aucun sens."
C'est insensé,
de recevoir ce type de verdicts.
Donc, en fait, quelque part,
j'ai eu l'impression
d'être responsable
du fait que cet individu
continue à faire du mal.
Ca, je l'ai porté seule,
car ces gens n'en n'avaient
rien à faire.
-Il aura fallu attendre
une cinquième accusatrice
pour qu'il lui soit interdit
de recevoir des patientes mineures.
38 ans après la première plainte.
Musique sombre
...
Le conseil de l'Ordre est parfois
plus sévère avec ceux qui dénoncent
les violences qu'avec les violeurs.
C'est ce qui s'est produit
dans l'affaire du docteur Hazout.
...
Richard Poitevin,
le mari de Cécile,
la plaignante,
était lui-même médecin,
chef de service dans un hôpital
en Ile-de-France.
...
Pour avoir dénoncé
auprès des institutions
ordinales le viol de sa femme,
il a été puni d'un blâme.
C'est la sanction
qui précède la radiation.
-Ce qui m'est arrivé,
c'était en 2004.
Notre 1e plainte,
auprès du conseil de l'Ordre,
date d'avril 2005.
-Même en prenant des précautions,
euh... Je prenais un risque.
Et effectivement,
j'ai eu ce blâme pour diffamation.
Mais...
-On vous punit.
-C'est d'ailleurs pour ça...
J'arrivais plus...
Enfin, j'ai eu du mal
à accepter tout cela.
-Très affecté,
il a dû quitter son service
et déménagé dans le sud
de la France.
...
-Tu vas pas par là.
Tu viens par ici.
-D'autres médecins
sont sanctionnés
par les chambres disciplinaires
de l'Ordre
pour avoir signalé
des violences commises
sur des femmes,
ou des enfants.
-Ils sont nuisibles et complices
des agresseurs sexuels.
C'est-à-dire...
Ils protègent les collègues
présumés agresseurs sexuels
et ils engueulent les collègues
qui dénoncent les agressions
sexuelles auprès des enfants.
Je sais pas pourquoi
ils sont comme ça
mais ça donne ça,
comme notion.
Dans le journal
du conseil de l'Ordre,
il y avait les condamnations.
Un gars était condamné à 8 jours
de suspension d'exercice,
car il avait fait faire
une fellation à un enfant de 5 ans
lors d'un examen ORL.
C'était 8 jours de suspension.
C'était décrit ainsi,
tranquillement.
C'était il y a 35 ans, je l'ai plus,
mais on est dans des trucs de fou.
Musique pesante
-Des jeunes filles tombées
dans un effroyable piège,
celui de Jeffrey Epstein.
A son tour, elle témoigne,
Adèle Haenel, avant-garde
d'un MeToo du cinéma français.
Elle accuse le cinéaste...
C'est le récit glacial
d'une jeune fille sous emprise.
Il secoue le monde de l'édition
avant même sa sortie.
"Le consentement",
de Vanessa Springora...
Elle avait 21 ans,
lui, 36 de plus,
Florence Porcel a déposé plainte
contre Patrick Poivre d'Arvor,
icône cathodique.
...
-Depuis la déflagration de MeToo,
les victimes
de violences sexuelles sortent
du silence qui leur a été imposé.
Sur les réseaux sociaux,
dans les médias et dans la rue,
elles savent se faire entendre.
La parole ne s'est pas libérée,
c'est la société qui, enfin,
écoute et croit les victimes.
Cris et tambours
...
Mais ce changement de paradigme
a-t-il touché l'Ordre des médecins ?
Au siège de l'institution ordinale,
en 2021, les consignes ont changé.
Les échelons départementaux
de l'Ordre sont appelés
à mieux écouter les plaignantes.
-Dans les faits,
à connotation sexuelle,
nous invitions très fortement
les conseils départementaux
à porter plainte
contre les médecins,
qui auront à répondre,
avec le respect
des droits de la défense,
devant les chambres disciplinaires
des comportements
qui leur sont reprochés.
On ne se réfugie pas
derrière le fait que
c'est parole contre parole.
On ne veut plus
et on ne peut plus l'entendre.
C'est très clair...
Il n'y a aucune ambiguïté.
Aucune ambiguïté, là-dessus.
-Un an plus tard,
l'ambiguïté demeure.
Dans cette ville du Pas-de-Calais,
70 femmes, âgées de 27
à 47 ans, ont porté plainte
contre le même gynécologue.
Le docteur Bernard Henric.
Pour agressions sexuelles et viols.
Musique intense
...
Vendeuse, enseignante,
infirmière,
fonctionnaire de police,
psychologue,
comptable,
assistante de direction...
Auditionnées
par le juge d'instruction,
toutes décrivent
des séances sexualisées.
Des récits concordants de femmes
qui ne se connaissent pas.
-Il mettait plusieurs doigts.
Toujours son pouce sur le clitoris
avec une main au-dessus.
Il faisait des va-et-vient,
en bougeant la main.
Je sens, un moment donné,
un souffle.
Et un passage de langue.
Quelques minutes après,
je sens le souffle
et je me dis : "Il recommence."
Un deuxième passage de langue.
Parfois, ça durait longtemps.
Une fois, ça m'avait fait mal
parce que c'était tout sec,
à force des va-et-vient.
Je lui ai dit et il s'est énervé
en disant que c'était
bientôt terminé.
J'ai eu une 3e respiration
au niveau du clitoris
et un autre passage de langue.
Et j'entends
des bruits de tissus,
et il me dit :
"J'ai bientôt fini."
Je me dis :
"C'est pas possible,
"il est en train
de se faire plaisir."
-L'affaire est en instruction
depuis sept ans.
Mis en examen,
le docteur Henric reçoit toujours
des patientes.
Le conseil de l'Ordre
de Pas-de-Calais
ne l'a pas suspendu.
La justice lui interdit
d'exercer la gynécologie,
mais l'autorise à exercer
une autre de ses spécialités.
-Il continue d'exercer
au terme du contrôle judiciaire
dont il est astreint, il continue
à exercer l'endocrinologie
dans son cabinet.
Et vous dire que c'est
particulièrement difficile,
pour mes clientes,
d'accepter,
malgré le fait
qu'il soit
présumé innocent, qu'il puisse
encore exercer la médecine.
-Il a toujours accès
au corps des femmes.
En tant qu'endocrinologue,
il fait l'objet
d'une nouvelle plainte pour viol.
Combien faut-il de témoignages
pour qu'on écoute
la parole des femmes ?
Au conseil national
de l'Ordre des médecins,
cette fois,
c'est une femme qui répond.
-En tant que femme médecin,
je suis terriblement impactée
par ces faits-là.
Je lis la presse,
comme tout le monde,
et quand je lis
ces témoignages...
je suis horrifiée,
bien sûr.
C'est difficile d'envisager
que quelqu'un de sa corporation
puisse violenter,
avoir...
des attitudes inappropriées,
allant jusqu'à la violence sexuelle
et le viol.
Je veux dire,
quelque part... Voilà.
-Comment vous expliquez, vous,
que le conseil de l'Ordre
ne suspense pas à titre provisoire
ce médecin,
qui a 70 plaintes aujourd'hui
au pénal,
et qui est mis en examen
depuis 2015 ?
-Alors je...
Je ne peux pas commenter
des affaires en cours.
C'est lié, et ça, je pense
que l'institution ordinale
a fait son mea culpa,
c'est lié à une inaction
à un certain moment.
-Pourquoi la chambre disciplinaire
ne radie pas des médecins ?
-C'est pas de la mauvaise foi,
ce que je suis en train de dire,
mais pour le cas
dont vous me parlez,
on attend la décision
de la chambre disciplinaire,
voilà.
-Non seulement le conseil de l'Ordre
a le plus grand mal à sanctionner,
mais il ne signale pas les faits
dont il a connaissance à la justice.
Cette inertie explique pourquoi
des médecins accusés
par de nombreuses patientes
continuent d'exercer impunément
pendant des dizaines d'années.
Mais aujourd'hui, les violences
commises par des soignants
sont devenues inacceptables.
Une nouvelle génération
de femmes exigent
de pouvoir exprimer son consentement
avant tout acte médical.
-C'est pas parce qu'il y a
des spécialités
où on rentre dans l'intimité
de la personne
qu'on doit les abuser et les violer,
que ça soit clair.
C'est pas parce qu'une femme
va à sa consultation de gynécologie
que le consentement est acquis.
Voilà.
Mais tout ça, c'est des paradigmes
qui changent.
Il y a 30 ans,
on pouvait considérer
qu'une femme qui allait faire
une consultation,
le consentement était acquis
parce que finalement,
les luttes et les débats féministes,
il y a plus de 30 ans,
c'était la contraception,
c'était la légalisation
de l'avortement.
Maintenant,
on est dans d'autres dimensions
qui font que...
on est dans le recueil
du consentement.
Musique douce
-L'Ordre des médecins
promet de se mettre
au diapason
de son époque.
Mais l'institution a toujours eu
un train de retard sur la société.
-Il y avait dans le temps
un truc sur :
tu ne participeras pas
à l'avortement.
Le conseil de l'Ordre
a été créé par Pétain
et c'est très réactionnaire.
-Après des années
à tenter d'oublier,
l'histoire d'Anne lui revient
de manière inattendue.
En décembre 2019,
la Cour des comptes
publie un rapport sévère
sur l'Ordre des médecins.
Musique de tension
Elle y dénonce
les manquements nombreux
en matière de déontologie...
...
et réclame des garanties
de procès équitables
pour les citoyens.
...
Dans les pages
consacrées aux agressions sexuelles,
Anne reconnaît son affaire.
...
-En fait, je m'étais
toujours sentie, comment dire,
illégitime à parler,
parce j'avais complètement
intériorisé leur jugement négatif,
et le fait qu'ils avaient prétendu
que je m'étais précipitée
sur la personne,
et tout ce discours inversé
sur mes actes
et sur ce qui s'était
vraiment passé.
Donc je n'osais pas parler,
et tout d'un coup,
ce rapport m'a donné
une forme de légitimité,
et je me suis dit :
"Je vais recenser
"régulièrement
toutes les violences sexuelles
"commises par des professionnels
de santé,
"par des médecins
dont je peux trouver mention
"dans les journaux,
sur le web, etc."
-Depuis trois ans,
elle anime le hashtag
"violences sexuelles médecins",
suivi par 2000 personnes.
-A un moment donné,
il y avait
une ou deux affaires
qui sortait par semaine
médiatiquement en France.
J'ai interpellé les ministres
de la Santé successifs
depuis Agnès Buzyn,
donc Olivier Véran
et puis maintenant François Braun.
J'ai interpellé d'autres ministres,
comme Elisabeth Moreno
et Isabelle Rome.
J'interpelle aussi la commission
des affaires sociales
de l'Assemblée nationale
puisqu'elle serait légitime
à agir sur ce sujet,
la délégation de droits des femmes.
Je n'ai obtenu aucune réaction
d'aucune sorte d'aucun ministre.
Je me heurte à une indifférence
sur le sujet.
Mais en fait, à ma connaissance,
il n'y a pas de réponse officielle
sur les suites données à ce rapport,
et sur les réformes mises en oeuvre.
C'est le sens, aujourd'hui,
de ce hashtag,
c'est de faire en sorte
que le système soit réformé
et qu'il soit assaini
et qu'il soit digne de confiance.
...
-Il y a cinq ans,
jour pour jour,
paraissait dans le New York Times
l'enquête qui fera tomber
l'un des producteurs
les plus influents d'Hollywood,
Harvey Weinstein,
et qui donnera naissance au hashtag
lancé par l'actrice Alyssa Milano,
"MeToo", deux petits mots
qui ont changé le monde
et ouvert la voie à une nouvelle
génération féministe.
Depuis cinq ans,
le mouvement MeToo
a gagné de nombreuses professions :
le sport, le cinéma, les médias,
la politique.
Et qu'en est-il
du monde des médecins ?
-A ma connaissance,
il y a pas de MeToo médecins,
mais peut-être qu'il y en a un
dans un coin qu'on n'a pas vu,
mais moi, j'ai pas encore vu
de choses comme ça.
...
-Voici 11 ans que nous rencontrons
des victimes de médecins.
11 ans
que nous écoutons leurs souffrances,
11 ans qu'elles réclament
une justice équitable.
...
Pour mettre fin
à la complaisance envers
les violeurs
en blouse blanche,
n'est-il pas temps
de mettre en cause
le conseil de l'Ordre et de faire
des médecins des justiciables
comme les autres ?
...
-Je vais mieux,
mais je souffre quand même
encore de stress post-traumatique.
La reconstruction, elle passe déjà
par l'estime de soi...
et consoler la petite fille
que j'étais,
qui a souffert aussi,
et consolait même la jeune femme
ou la femme que j'ai été,
qui a souffert aussi, et...
Et quand même, la vie est belle
et ça vaut le coup de la vivre.
Même si c'est que des instants
de bonheur
ou des petits moments de bonheur,
il faut les prendre à pleines dents.
Musique mélancolique
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA